i got a call saying they you know they'd
seen a tape i'd posted a tape what am i
in like the 90s um
they saw my tape um yeah they were like
hey what you do is really interesting
we'd love you to
come audition and i was like all that
hard work this
is my make or break i kept making it all
the way until the quarterfinals
instead of looking at how far i'd come
on this show being a violinist that had
never performed in front of anyone more
than like a cafeteria of people who
weren't listening being on stages like
that in front of
millions of people on tv very different
i was performing and i got x in the
middle of my performance just
like they only do that if they like hate
what you're doing it's not like oh it's
okay it's like we hated it so much that
i got x
listening to them say these things to me
that were just like so hurtful and
trying not to cry on national television
just being
like and in my mind i'm like i told
every friend i've ever met to watch
tonight
and to vote for me like oh my gosh i was
humiliated
this podcast exists because i
love talking to people and i love going
deep the purpose
is to plant seeds of inspiration we
enter a space of vulnerability and
relatability and what you realize is
that we
are so much more alike than we are
different to quote ramdas
we're all just walking each other home
and this show
is just one step i'm danica patrick and
i'm pretty intense
hello today on the show is lindsay
sterling
she is an incredible
violinist performer she plays the violin
while
dancing and doing crazy things and maybe
you even saw her
uh this past holiday season hanging from
her hair
on a virtual show a virtual performance
she put on
uh she's an incredible human that really
i'm just gonna say
gets it like the the reason why she's
successful
is she just knows how to work hard as
well as
manifest the things in her life that she
wants but
it doesn't come without its cost she's a
really really you know
big perfectionist so we dive into
the nature of that you know not being
able to sort of
see herself for her you know
accomplishments and honor the inner
child and
all of that stuff that makes life a
little bit less fun at the end of the
day if we're going to be put in tough
situations
uh the only thing worse than the tough
situation is coming away with that
away without some kind of a lesson but
she's definitely put the time to good
use and
um big things are coming for her so wait
till the end of the episode you'll hear
exactly
what it is that she wants from her
personal and professional life that
would uh
that's at the top of the list for the
most out there goals so
i hope you enjoy this episode uh you
have a don't you have an
asteroid named after you yes my fans
gave it to me for christmas one year how
sweet is that are you into astrology
i'm not like actually super into
astrology
um you know like i don't know much about
my sign i like take that stuff with a
grain
of salt and whenever i catch pieces of
it i always like
i like to believe that you know it's
like i take bits and pieces here and
there
what um uh what are you i'm a virgo
i was just gonna ask you before we
started or
right before you asked that i was going
to say are you a ver virgo
why did i say that um because
virgos are uh perfectionists
they're analytical they're um
practical they're overachievers
essentially
and very fixated with health and
perfectionism
and so uh i have um
some virgo in my chart and so i'm
speaking from experience too
and i always say that the worst thing
about a virgo is you're um
you're an overachiever and so you do
achieve
great things yet the the virgo element
doesn't
allow you to feel it and and believe it
and
acknowledge it and own it you're
speaking my language
i know it's yeah it's the
that's the hardest part so i always
wonder if it's worse to
achieve great things and not feel it or
just not achieve them but feel like you
whatever you did was baller
right yes i totally have actually
thought of this before
like what's the better reality to live
in because you do live in your own
reality and it's like yeah what reality
would you want to paint for yourself
like i don't know so it's interesting
yeah so the perfectionism resonates with
you
the for the analytics the
practical the credit like what were you
thinking of when i said that
um yes there are definitely parts it's
funny i feel like i
um i'm like split in half and um i'm a
very like
like in one side i'm super free-spirited
and just like fun-loving and then
there's this other
very strong half of me that's very like
goal-oriented
perfectionistic like has to achieve
always analyzing and like you know like
you said not always seeing the value in
like what i've done
and so it's funny i feel like i have
these two like battling sides of myself
and at different times of my life i've
been like
you know this side's gotten stronger and
then this side's stronger so it's like
hmm you know they they each play a part
in my life
so yeah it'd be interesting to know what
your chart was i
i took a couple levels of astrology so i
can i can read uh
i can kind of oh very cool but anyway we
won't worry about that your sun sign is
obviously the most prominent mine i'm in
aries so it's uh
hence my you know red and the ridiculous
red i have going on all around me but um
but uh so uh the other thing is you grew
up in arizona i live in scottsdale
oh no way yes arizona girl through uh
i was grew up in gilbert yeah do you
miss it
i do i love it there and my mom and one
of my sisters still lives there and so
that's kind of always going to be like
home base for our family
um because that's where we always go for
christmases and you know it's
it'll always be like home and i love
that it's just a quick
car ride away like i can literally just
on a whim be like i'm going to see my
mom
like jump in my car and be in arizona um
because you're probably in la right
mm-hmm yeah whenever i drive to la or
laguna or anywhere out that direction
i always drive too i mean it's
imaginable that i would drive probably
based on my past but
um but yeah yeah yeah such an easy drive
and i feel like i just you know cruises
traffic at about 95 which always
is nice yeah put some good tunes listen
to an audiobook or something and get to
like kind of check out for a little bit
you know rather than yeah dealing with
the airport which takes about the same
amount of time anyway once you've like
done the whole thing
exactly okay well if you were gonna be
on a car ride
on your own for six hours what what what
is it that you're putting on or what
have you put on recently
to to pass the time when you've driven
let's see last time i
drove i listened to some of daring
greatly from brene brown
it's one of my favorite books of all
time i feel like it's something i need
to read
every few years to like just put myself
in a
like every time i read it i'm like yes i
just feel like i understand like my
relationship with the world a little
better and a little less personally
and so i love that book so i read that
last time i was going and i would
intersperse it with like just
today's hot uh top hits playlist to like
you know when i'd start to get sleepy
from like you know
self-help book world will do that to you
totally no i'd start to get sleepy i'd
be like all right trying to put on some
of the new
top hits of today and and let's go
yes all the way like oh i have to try to
keep up with this stuff sometimes i'm
like i have no idea what the hits are
and i'm like i should know this stuff
i'm a musician this is my
this is my world well i mean that's
actually i just thought how fascinating
it is like
just you know i'm sure you've you've
been asked a ton of times what you
listen to for music but
you know playing the violin and having
that be sort of more of like a
i don't it's not really classical but
it's kind of classical right like how
would you categorize it it's
instrumental it's
uh classical instrumental like new age
vibe well i mean the violin is like such
a
classical instrument but i do not play
it in a classical way
at all like it's funny how you know i
still like
shifts on my sheet music right here i
still practice classical music
to try to like keep up on that skill
level because there's nothing that will
get your chops good as much as like
class music but it's just a totally
different way of playing and i don't
even
call myself a classical violinist
because i have so much respect for like
that art is something different and what
i do is just kind of this mixture of
different sounds and tunes very new age
um but just using the violin as my voice
yeah and your body i mean because you're
you know with dancing and moving i mean
like that
there's absolutely a transmission of
information
with that too and what i i think is
crazy is that
how you ended up being able to come back
around
in your life from being told as a child
that you need to pick either dance or
violin
and then you're like gotcha do both now
like how did that first off was that i
mean
when you're told or that you can't do
both of them
and you have to pick was that difficult
or was it easy at that point
um i was six years old and so
you know and i definitely understand it
wasn't my parents being like you can't
do this
it was like we literally can't afford
to give you either and like i understood
to a certain extent
that like i didn't really understand
that we had money problems but i
understood it you know what i mean
um and so being a young kid that's
actually one of the reasons i practiced
so hard was because i knew that if i
didn't practice
my mom was not going to keep paying for
lessons that i did not
practice for like they just did not have
the money to invest into some
kid that was wasting their lessons it
wasn't like you will play the violin
i had to earn that um but you know so
when i was
told i had to pick like they took me to
a dance class and they took me to a
violin lesson and they're like
all right which one do you want to do
you know the rest of your life basically
um and i think i was just so darn
intimidated in the dance class because
like there was all these other girls and
they knew
the little warm-up exercises and so i
was like i'll do the violin like it was
a private lesson i was by myself
no one was looking at me you know so but
my whole life i've just always wanted to
dance
i remember i even auditioned my best
friend and i from high school laughed
about it that we auditioned for the high
school dance team and we had no business
being in that room like we'd laugh about
it
because we like made fools of ourselves
because we just wanted to dance you know
and of course we didn't make it
um and then it wasn't till i was in
college that i thought well why can't i
like
at least move and express with the
violin like i can do that
and it just has grown from there wow so
it wasn't until
much later that the dancing came yes
like
and it's funny people like kind of
assume that i you know was a dancer and
then combined with the violin but like
absolutely not like in college i
had never danced in my life and i just
started to like i said it was just
starting with like movement and then i
was like
look i started to learn about like foot
placement and
oh that's called first position like oh
you turn out interesting
you know so i started to learn like the
proper form and but it was all
self-taught
tiny baby steps really your dance is
self-taught
yes all of it i mean i the first time i
ever had training was on dancing with
the stars
which was like three years ago wow
wow so how did it feel to ha
obviously you probably weren't playing
the violin
when you started dancing and learning
how to dance right you probably weren't
going like
oh i'm gonna move oh that felt good like
right it had to have been a separate
sort of practice from the violin at
first
yes i would just kind of think to myself
like what could i do and so i would like
look at videos of dancers and i'd see
like well that's a cool move that they
did
only with their leg okay like i could
incorporate that and i just like
pick and choose little pieces here and
there and i'd choreograph you know
these really funny little basically they
were just movements at first i couldn't
even call it dancing
um but yeah i would practice it by
itself you know and it probably looks so
funny because i'm just doing all these
moves with my legs
like with nothing in my hands and once i
had that memorized i would start to
slowly like
combine it with the violin plane but
always with the intention of knowing
that you couldn't use your
your hands and your arms right right yes
and even now when i work with
choreographers like a lot of times i
have to remind them like
you know because they'll be
choreographing for like a stage
performance with like my four dancers or
something and they'll be
putting so many hand movements in it and
i was you know and i'll be like
that's really cool but you added a
little bit of movement so that i can at
least like look apart
with them and they'll be like right
right right you know so i've worked with
choreographers like over and over again
at this point that understand the way i
like to move and
you know the world i live in so that
they can choreograph to my needs not
just to the dancers needs
so why did you why did you start dancing
i started dancing because i wanted to be
a performer like i love you know i
always
like like loved playing the violin i
kind of lost my passion for it along the
way somewhere
and um i started to be like i need to
find
my voice in the violin not just like you
know i'd always just like look at sheet
music and just
regurgitated exactly what i was told to
play the way they told me to play it
like every
articulation is dictated through some
sort of a mark on the page
and i just lost the passion through that
i think it wasn't for me
and so once i discovered like i want to
figure out how
i can be the voice not the violin um it
made me excited about writing and then
the kind of music i was writing i was
like if i ever want to perform
something like this kind of music i
can't just stand there
i was like it doesn't feel right to me
it doesn't look right
and i was like as a person who loves
entertainment i was like
i wouldn't want to sit through a show
where someone would be standing there
and playing
this song it wouldn't fit to me so i was
like well i gotta make it visual i gotta
add some energy somehow so pretty much
just came from like what would i
as a consumer wanna see if i heard this
music and i was like i'd wanna see the
violinist dancing what i think is cool
is that what i'm hearing is that you
were always envisioning yourself
alone on the stage people were coming to
see
you you were not part of something you
were not
an aspect or in like even with anybody
or anything
it was you on the stage alone and i
think that's like
very confident and cool it's you know
funny looking back at it i don't know
where i got
that tenacity to be like i know that i
can
sell out shows by myself as a violinist
for an hour and a half set i know i can
do it you know like here i was a girl
that had no
following like i'm not sure where that
tenacity came from
but i was so determined and um my mom
even says she's like i knew you would
succeed because i just
like because you believed it so strongly
she's like i
of course i was worried as a mother
watching you go on this journey but
she's like but
i knew you'd make it like i feel like i
willed my career into existence i say
that often i just believed it so
strongly and
you know wouldn't stop trying new things
until
i figured out something that worked
thoughts become things
i 100 believe uh you you
dream big have a vision but the magic
sauce
that i always say is that you actually
believe it yes if you you can think all
kinds of stuff and it doesn't mean that
you know you might not get somewhere
with oh i want to play the violin
someday and then all of a sudden it kind
of leads to like
you know juilliard or whatever it ends
up being you know
but it's the belief in the vision
that actually anchors it absolutely well
because if you know i look back i think
to myself how hard like
anyone has to work like how hard i had
to work to get to where i'm at today
and like i said anybody that's like
chasing dreams you have to work your
tail off
and if you don't believe that especially
in the beginning
those thankless things you're doing that
aren't getting any traction if you don't
believe genuinely that they are steps
towards something
you know and if you're like i actually
don't believe i can do this there's no
way you're gonna keep
doing that thankless journey that's hard
and lonely
and you know and it feels kind of blind
sometimes and if you don't believe you
can do it there's no way
you're gonna keep after it i always call
that blind faith like
there was a lot of reasons why i didn't
feel like i was
why i shouldn't have made it in racing
except all i can say
is that i just had blind faith and i
believed that it was gonna work
yeah like no damn reason like i'm 19
years old coming back from england with
a ged
and no job for like basically two years
and like no reason and then a couple of
years after that i'm driving an indy car
and almost won the indy 500. like
there's no good reason
why it worked out there's but there's
got there's
it i get that but tell me about your
parents
what were they like and was one of them
a really big dreamer
or uh supported you in a way that felt
um empowering did they lead by example
yes my parents both were so supportive
i'm sure that played a huge role in my
belief in myself
is because i you know i knew that they
were my biggest fans you know and they
they would show up continuously to
whatever it was that i
was excited about and dreaming about um
you know they were always there
and i remember i think one of the most
impactful
things from my childhood is that my dad
um
he was a great storyteller and he was a
writer like he actually
wanted to be like a film writer right
screenplays
and he had like these different
screenplays that he had written
and he would read them to me as like
bedtime stories or he would also tell us
tales from his own life and sometimes i
couldn't tell
which were the tales from his own
adventures and which were
the made-up stories he would almost like
sometimes melt the two together
and so it was just such a fun world to
grow up in
where these were stories he had created
somehow in his life and i remember from
a really early age
saying dad i want to live a life like
you
i want to travel to places i want to
meet people i want to do things
um and he said you will you will you
know and just that
sense that he had lived a life of
adventure not because he
succeeded at all of his dreams he
actually never became that famous
screenplay writer that he wanted to be
but boy he went for it
and he he lived a life of adventure
because he tried
and he loved his life you know he had a
family and he
you know he ended up being a teacher and
he loved being a teacher but also
the great stories came from the fact
that he tried
and so it kind of taught me that there's
no shame in going
after what you want in life and you know
because whether
you end up at the goal you imagined or
not you will live a colorful life and go
places and meet people and see things
and have stories
um and i wanted more than anything so
it's almost kind of like he taught me
the value of
the journey and that's what i was
actually seeking for
ah that's great i i was i refer to this
book all the time but
mindset by carol dewack is about um you
know just
a growth versus fixed mindset and
um sort of the point is to really orient
and fixate and look at the effort and
the journey
and um instead of the accomplishment
uh because then basically you spend most
of the time in journey anyway and so
instead of like i i think it's
fascinating that you know people
that are put into this fixed mindset
where it's all about accomplishment
they totally they don't even do things
because they're so afraid of failing
because that is more traumatizing
than than than doing it and then doing
it and being successful
like the the that exceeds the pain of
failing
exceeds the joy of succeeding
ooh increasingly powerful
you know and it is interesting you know
because even going back to what you said
at the very beginning of like
you know being a virgo sometimes we
don't always you know i don't always see
the accomplishments of
you know because we're i'm so fixed on
like the goal and it's been
a journey for me to learn to see where
i'm at
and to enjoy where i'm at rather than
just focusing on
where i'm going because that way you
don't even appreciate like
where you're at and what you've worked
that once upon time you were working to
get here
and now that you're here am i just
focusing on the next thing you know but
no stopping and being like
i love the process because like you said
most of life is made up of the process
like
getting to the top of the hill is only
like minutes only moments
and it's fleeting right because once you
get there you are like now what
there's almost like or it's like or you
know with our little disease of
not believing we actually did anything
great we're like yeah but you know
i mean this door kind of got opened for
me and like you know i mean this kind of
happened and i got lucky and
you know right right can you relate i'm
like
you know i can blow off some
accomplishments to just like
circumstance or luck
um but uh yeah what was was there
um what would what do you feel like was
the point in time where you had to like
grit up the most and be and and
and remind yourself of just what you
believed in
because you know the [ __ ] hit the fan
and you weren't feeling you weren't
feeling
hopeful oh my gosh definitely i could
think of like several points um
but i mean the biggest one the most
public one was definitely um
when i went on to america's got talent
2010
and at this point it wasn't like my
first time
trying like i had been trying to be a
performer you know
like for a year i'd been traveling to
random colleges playing in cafeterias
like
doing that thankless work that you're
like this is literally going nowhere
and you know i remember like sleeping in
my car one time just being like
this is so lonely like i just don't know
how much longer i could do this
and then i got a call saying they you
know they'd seen a tape i'd posted and
they wanted to
a tape what am i in like this 90s um
you're helping me feel relevant okay
they saw my tape
um but yeah they were like hey what you
do is really interesting we'd love for
you to
come audition and i was like this is it
all that hard work this is my make or
break i got this
like i'm gonna kill this and i like
worked so hard and practiced for months
and i went through that first audition
and made it
got to the second phase made it through
and i kept making it all the way until
the quarterfinals
and you would think that that would be
like a hey i made it pretty far
but instead i focused on
instead of looking at how far i'd come
on the show being a violinist that had
never performed in front of anyone more
than like a cafeteria of people who
weren't listening you know
being on stage is like that in front of
millions of people on tv
very different and so rather than being
like wow good job linds um
when i was in the quarterfinals i got up
there
i was performing and i got x in the
middle of my performance which is like
humiliating like just like they only do
that if they like
hate what you're doing it's not like oh
it's okay it's like we hated it so much
that i got x
and i just remember standing there
talking to them on live tv
after my performance and just listening
to them say these things to me that were
just like
so hurtful and trying not to cry on
national television just being
like and in my mind i'm like i told
every friend i've ever met to watch
tonight
and to vote for me like oh my gosh i was
humiliated
um and i just i remember getting off
that stage and thinking
i will never step on a stage again i
can't face that
like it was horrifying and you know i
cried for hours like
you know and that feels like days and
you know finally after like
a few months the pain inside of me i
wouldn't say it turned into like i'm
gonna prove them wrong
maybe a little bit but also it was just
that inner voice that became stronger
than the pain
stronger than the embarrassment became
the voice of saying
you're not done yet like and i really do
feel so much
that you know i relate it to
spirituality and like my relationship
with god but
i believe we all have like some kind of
an inner voice
and if you listen to it it won't lead
you astray and it
kept getting stronger and stronger and i
just like
shoot this journey it's not done like i
need to keep trying and so i did i got
back up on stages i didn't even know
what the heck to do at this point i was
out of ideas but
just by stepping on little open mic
night stages again
the opportunity found me not there
anything i did
like it's just i kept taking the bait
wherever i could find it till i finally
bit on the right one
you got into flow yeah right
there's so many things that are coming
up but you mentioned spirituality and
as soon as you said inner voice i was
like i have to ask what your
relationship is with
um spirituality and higher self inner
child whatever
you want a god source you know any any
anything you want to call it
um so maybe let's start there because
what i'm hearing is that you
you know you you you you listen to it
you acknowledge it and so have
what is yeah what is your relationship
or would you call yourself religious
would you call yourself spiritual did
you have an experience or some moment in
time where something shifted where
you're like whoa what the hell is that
you know i was raised religious and i
used to always just answer this is like
i'm a religious person
and since you know and i'm still a
religious person you know i still go to
church on sundays and i consider myself
religious but it's become so much more
you know it's become very spiritual
feeling it's like a
very one-on-one relationship that i have
with not only god but through
experiences of loss it's i now believe
so strongly in angels
and i you know i lost my my father a few
years ago to cancer and
right before that i lost my best friend
to cancer and
i just was like you know what i know
that i've seen little signs
that they are around me and they're
looking out for me and you know some
people may say that like
you know they're not real like you're
just seeing what you want to believe
and if that's the case amazing i would
choose to believe that these signs i
would choose to look for the positivity
in my life that like
that's a sign that my dad is here with
me right now like i just got chills even
just thinking that like it gives me
i think it's like the energy of it it is
it's the energy of hope and like
i would choose any day to believe in the
things that
give me hope than the other and i truly
believe it's
real but anyways i just feel like i i
believe in all of the above that you
mentioned i believe in the inner child
like trusting
that truest form of yourself because i
think that's the closest you'll ever get
to like your spirit your own spirit is
that like
sweet inner child so i believe in all of
it yeah have you ever
done any inner child work no what's that
um well do you have do you have you ever
been to therapy
oh yes lots of therapy i hear you oh yes
lots up there i had two therapists for
the last year oh wow good free i mean i
definitely had one she
saw me a lot or assumed me a lot yeah
exactly
um i i mean inner child work is just you
know kind of tapping into
you uh so much of our programming
happens before we're
like six and so the inner child
like literally connecting asking to
speak to it
what does what does she look at you know
being a girl maybe she's a
girl maybe it's a boy i don't know but
you know what does she look like
how tall is she how does she act what is
her emotion what are her emotions
does she emote does she speak um like
tapping into and again i'm this is from
my own personal experience working
with the inner child but um and so a
professional therapist might have some
different techniques but
um but this is how i sort of would start
the conversation like you really start
to develop a relationship
with that inner child but then of course
it's access to your programming so it's
access to
why you get triggered it's access to why
you project
certain things it's access to why you
judge certain things
um it's access to you know basically
your just general program of how you
operate in the world i feel like i did i
definitely did some of that when i was
um
fighting anorexia you know something i
went through in my late teens early 20s
and that was i think one one of the
really helpful techniques was just
talking to the inner child it's so much
easier to love yourself
when you think of yourself as a little
girl whose body i'm hurting
you know and looking at her and being
like she was perfect
you know there was nothing wrong with
her and like it kind of helps you
humanize yourself
it helped me do that i agree i mean the
work that i've done too i i had to look
at like myself
as like my inner child as an actual
child yeah
because i never had boundaries before
and so i had to
look at the inner child as being
separate from me
because i wasn't able to do it for
myself yet and so i looked at it like it
was separate for me so that i could go
look at a situation and go if that
person treated
my child like that would i be okay with
that and it's like hell no
you know yeah like but i can handle it
i'll be here i'll put up the fight you
know i'll
be tough and you know but when it's
something separate from you it's like
the
it's like the gateway to yourself and
then eventually you embody that as
yourself and and and
so uh you can then hold those boundaries
and have
sort of more autonomy in the way that
you
operate as opposed to um
you know allow people to step on you or
or to abandon
yourself so again most of the time we
abandon that inner child right
yes i remember one time i saw what you
just said reminded me of like a fan art
my fans will make little fan arts like
i'm sure
yours do as well and they took a picture
of me as a child and then they took a
meet-and-greet photo of me where i was
with a child but they replaced
the child with me and there's a picture
of me like
you know smiling with you know giving a
hug to this like
version of my child's self and i
remember
i was just really struck by that that
composition of like oh my gosh like the
way i see a little child when they come
up to me at meet and greets like i just
get so excited
and like i i just want to love on them
and give them hugs and i just see them
so sweetly and i just thought what if i
like saw myself like that
what if i was that kind to myself you
know yeah
do you feel like there was a parallel in
time between
when you started dancing and sort of
looking at the inner child i'm not sure
when you dealt with anorexia and when
that point in time was
but there's is there some kind of
overlap to uh
to the dancing or did the dancing come
first
it was actually about the same time it
was shortly after
probably while i was in the middle of
like at this point i knew
i had a problem and i was working on it
going to lots of group therapy and
therapy like
it was kind of in the mix of all of that
um and it was
right about the time i feel like i'm
starting to get on top of it and that
because finally i had
energy again to like put into
myself and art and thinking of other
things you know than just the consuming
you know disease that i had and so i
think it was right at the cusp of like i
was starting to get better
i wonder if it's somewhat of your inner
child coming out and so
you know through the dance and the play
like the child wants to play
right absolutely do you feel like the
i'm curious if you feel like the music
moves your body or does your body move
the music
oh you know for me
i think because my i guess my first
language of art is definitely music
um the music moves the body for me
um but it's always fun to see
for example certain songs i will
choreograph my own movement if it's just
me
on stage i'll you know i'll figure out
what i'm gonna do but then when there's
my
dancers my dick my choreographer will
make the choreography for us and i'll
notice that
she's letting her body dictate
what the music says because she'll pick
different beats and different accents
than i would which is really
interesting because i'm like being led
by the music and although
she is too i think for her the forefront
is her body is reacting
first and so i always think that's
really cool when
she'll choose she'll make different
choices than i naturally would have
which i think is really fun have you
ever put
music to her put music to dance after
like see a dance or see her sort of
choreography or your own
and let that inspire music and just sort
of like
feel how that would you know like how
does the sound go when you when you do
the dance first
that would be really interesting to
write like that i've only done it like
that
like maybe once or twice and it was
actually
derek huff because he's very interesting
he'll he likes to kind of compose
you know or work on some of his songs
but it's based around the dance
um you know or he's thinking about dance
as he's choreographed or as he's writing
something he'll be like i need a hit
here because i wanted
you know and but i've worked with him to
like
work on songs before it's so fun to see
how he
thinks and you know watch him use
movement to convey to me what to play
which is like it'd be interesting to
write an original song like that because
i've never done that i've only worked
on derrick's stuff i'm curious like i
wonder if the inner child
in you is like okay i'm here i'm on
stage
all right i'm moving but i want to lead
the way
yes interesting move first and then
and then come i just feel like because
there's such inspiration both directions
but of course
you know your you know your your
pattern is to create the music and then
follow it with dance but
i don't know it's an interesting
timeline to when you started dancing
with everything that you were going
through which
you know uh you know my understanding of
eating disorders it's very much about
control absolutely are you able i mean
this is maybe just helpful because i
you know i was thinking the other day i
don't think there's probably a single
girl that hasn't gone through
a phase of some level of
an unhealthy relationship with food from
a control standpoint
or from a restriction standpoint or from
a some some other standpoint that
revolves around food so i mean anything
that you're
comfortable to share about where that
came from and what
helped you the most i think would be
helpful because it's just one of those
topics that if someone's brave enough to
speak about can be really
helpful yes and i agree with you i think
that
it's it's like a product of the western
way of thinking and the images were hit
with every day i think that
every girl to some extent is on that
spectrum
of like somewhere having a bad
relationship
with food or hating their body like some
sense of control around that and
um you know to the extent hopefully most
people can get it under control and
for me it happened so gradually that i
never
saw it and you know i but once i
realized the problem i was like
there were signs of this since i was
like a child you know i remember
putting on a snow suit when i was like
like i wasn't even eight years old yet
we were going
getting ready to go to the snow and like
put on the snow suit and i remember
thinking how fat i looked
and i was tiny like i was a tiny little
kid and i remember putting a
belt on like the snow suit and i told my
mom it was just to like hold it up
but it was because i wanted a waistline
at like seven years old
like what's that's strange and you know
i didn't think anything
but like slowly through time it became
an obsession and
for me what i always like share with
anyone who's struggling with this
is that um there's this odd mindset that
happens where you
feel like the eating disorder is you
you've and i think separating myself
from it the same way you were talking
about separating yourself from your
inner child like we're made up of so
many parts and conflictions and ideas
and this and that like we have so many
parts of ourself and we're so complex
it was so freeing to me to be able to
take my eating disorder and realize this
wasn't a part of me it's something that
had
come into me it's something that had
come on to me or whatever you want to
say
and by removing it i could say i don't
want you in my life anymore
i don't like what you've done to me and
i could treat it like a dysfunctional
relationship
with something else rather than a broken
part of my own spirit um and i would
talk to it like i would have
full-blown you know i read a book called
life without ed that was the most
changing book for me
in my recovery you know aside from like
therapy and
group therapy like i worked really hard
on my eating disorder once i realized
what the problem was because i was so
miserable that i was like
almost relieved when i realized what the
problem was even though it was like so
hard to say it the first time i remember
like talking to my mom on the phone and
finally saying
i think i have an eating disorder
because she had been telling me for a
while that she thought anyways but
once i said it it was like oh my gosh i
know what the problem is now
i can fix it like i know how to fix
problems i you know
i've done that before i learned how to
play the violin and i've taught myself
other things like i can learn this and
um but yeah i really turned it into a
part-time job and i think the biggest
thing for me was learning to separate
the broken self feeling because that's
an awful feeling when you feel like
you're the broken thing
there's a shame in that shame so much
shame and when you realize
that like we are never broken like that
broken things
happen to us like things will injure our
heart you know but it's not that our
heart is
bad it's that it got injured it's not
that you know our spirit is bad it's
just that it's been
hurt and so anyways that was the biggest
thing for me and i would literally talk
to it i've had conversations with it
until
i called it ed eating disorder and i
would just be like
i don't deserve to feel that way like
i'm not gonna let you tell me
that i you know and i still everyone so
i start to feel like kind of come back
i'm just like
i've done without you for a really long
time i don't need you in my life and i'm
not going to let you
make me feel like that about my body and
even though sometimes that's hard to say
because i'm like but right now i do feel
like that about my body and it's like
but i'm not gonna let you tell me
to i don't want you in my life yeah
that's super powerful to
separate it from you i've never heard it
described like that that's that's so
smart um because it's really the mind is
so powerful the mind created it the mind
can get rid of it
exactly and you at your core are whole
and perfect and pure and anything
else is just the reason why it doesn't
feel good is because it's not you
yeah yes and i remember like i had a
dream one night where
it was like creepiest dream i've ever
had and it was my eating disorder was
this
scary woman who was controlling
everything i did
and i was the only person that could see
her and i was at a party with
a bunch of people in the room and she
just followed me and
every time i'd do anything she would
hand me a piece of paper
and i'd have to sign a contract with her
and she'd take it like it's like she
knew everything i was doing
and controlling it and it was the
creepiest dream and i remember waking up
just being like
that's my life i don't want that anymore
i don't want to be controlled by this
thing
it's not me wow wow was that
i mean did that stuff start to peek in i
mean because
you know i you you were much younger so
you talked about dancing in college
right so you would have been
barely 20. um i mean then you go on
stage and now you're like now you're on
stage all the time and
it does it desensitize you even more to
those
thought patterns or does it make it come
up
even more where you have to like
practice the
self you know self love is so overused
but practice
that sort of disassociation with the
thoughts and realize that they're not
gonna
to not want them to be a part of your
part of your life
um or you know which side of it does it
fall for you
um you know i honestly think it hasn't
changed it
i feel like success or notoriety or any
of that stuff it doesn't actually
change who you are it just like
amplifies whatever you are
and so i feel like the same
triggers the same insecurities that you
know the same things i'm confident about
since becoming like more successful in
life they've been having more money or
whatever you want to say
they've only all gotten bigger and i
just have to kind of keep
working on all the same things um you
know and i continuously get better at
them but that's one of them is it will
come back and when it comes back it
um and it when i say come back i've
never i haven't relapsed
you know since like my first relapse you
know
in recovery but the feelings will come
back
and i have to nip it in the bud before
it
because i know what it could do to me
and so um and it's funny even with my
friends like you said everybody's got
some sort of a
relationship with food and i'll talk to
my friends who
um they never had eating disorders you
know or clinically
described eating disorders but yet we'll
talk about the relationship with food
and how
it's hard sometimes to be like is this
me being
healthy and aware that maybe i do need
to take a little better charge of my
my body and my diet or is this my mind
being unhealthy and lying to me and
being mean and it's like this
constant battle to like evaluate and for
me it just comes from
what's the source like what's the actual
source of why i feel this way
yeah and you know where is it coming
from and that can help me evaluate like
why is it valid for me to like think i
need to do a little better you know
because
there's value in that or is it me
beating myself up because i have
low self-worth because i don't think i'm
enough you know
um anyway so it's a constant little
battle but i just um
i've gotten really good at recognizing
when it starts to come back
what helps you stay in tune because that
to me is like attunement you know
absolutely able to track yourself and
know how you're feeling
staying staying in touch with yourself
other things that you do
to stay present i think
a lot of it comes around to like the
people you surround yourself with
like i remember being kind of nervous
the first time i had a bunch of female
dancers on tour with me i was like is
you know they were
much younger than i was he's like little
tiny fit things and
i remember thinking like this is gonna
like make me feel less about my body
but the kind of people they were and the
way they treated their bodies with
respect
made it fine you know and i realized
like this isn't going to be a problem
for me you know so i think it's also
just like
learning what does actually trigger you
learning the things
that like oh that's always going to make
me question myself when i
i'm around that you know just by
learning my triggers
um it's really helped me and like i said
it's just practice
the more times i've started to feel that
feeling the less
far i've let it get yeah yeah and then
getting rid of them it's like you know i
think a lot of us can kind of look and
see like what triggers us but
there's almost like a unhealthy like
relationship with wanting more of it
because we're familiar with that sort of
loop of thinking where we were like oh
let's just look at that let's just see
let's just let's just and you kind of
just go to the well again even though
it's like so many so many you know
coaches and
spiritual teachers and doctors and you
know
in the more in the esoteric sort of
realm of thinking and feeling and
manifesting would say that
you know it's not it doesn't mean it's
good it's just familiar and so it's like
we get addicted
to the hormone sort of like triggering
system
learned a lot about that from uh nicole
lapera who is the holistic psychologist
you know like it's like a it's like a
loop you know there's an
action there's a reaction and then we
just keep kind of going around and round
and round and
we want that sort of hormone spike
whatever it is it's like it doesn't
matter
it's like people know that are on drugs
it's bad for you but you still want it
again it's the same for that sort of
um uh fixation on something mentally
that you've
you've done that creates a little
reaction
getting rid of them is super brave it
doesn't have to be a good reaction
either like no
i was being tortured absolutely tortured
and miserable from my eating disorder
but it's like
we want consistency so bad we want to
understand we like familiarity
and so even though it's hurting you it's
this weird comfort
um because you understand it and you
have a relationship with it and like you
said
even if it's giving you a bad reaction
it's making you feel something
um and you know and all these little
triggers like i think
things for me are like and they're not
bad things they're things i've learned
are bad for me
i don't have a scale in my house if i
had a scale in my house i would weigh
myself 10 times today like
guaranteed so i if they're in my hotel
room i call the front desk and they take
it out you know like i just don't
if i go to the doctor i usually turn
around i don't look at numbers it's not
healthy for me
same with like food journals they're so
good for some people
not for me can't you know like so i it's
realizing
yes that may work really well for her
but that
hurts me like it makes me focus on the
wrong thing
we've talked so much about you know some
of the tough stuff but
you know in typical virgo fashion
there's so much great stuff
so much in fact there's more um
i'm curious what this um
perfectionistic nature like we've seen
some of the manifestations
of like perfectionism that aren't as
feel good but what are the ones that do
like what are the times where you can be
so proud of yourself for working your
ass off and having a vision and like
what were there some points in time
where things happen where you're like
good job
yes i have i mean
i love putting on a show you know the
same way i was like i have to figure out
how to
be entertaining somehow that's mine
still is so alive in me and when i
like i love not only giving a show i
love the process of planning what i
think is going to be
a great show and i am so meticulously
like over involved in all the details i
mean i'll be
sewing accessories on costumes till the
night before the show like literally
i'll be like
uh well i'd like to have people to help
me but there's always
ones that i'm like i ran out of budget
and i still want that so it's like
i'm gonna figure out how to make it
myself you know like that's just very
me to like i'm like well if the budget
runs out i'll i'll get it done i'll
figure it out
you know and a lot of the videos on
screen when i ran out of budget for my
video budget
of the backgrounds like i'll make the
rest of them i'll find footage i'll edit
them you know so i'm just
very very very hands-on and
so when that show happens
when it goes off on the first night and
like i get to look into the eyes of the
audience members
you know if there's nothing that feels
like that's why i miss touring so much
is like
that feeling of like exchanging love
like i have this exceedingly amount like
of love that comes out of me when i
perform
probably because the like months and the
hours and the sleepless nights and the
sewing accessories that i spent
to get that show to these people and
then to feel their love back
is like it's such a connecting moment
for me it's the best feeling ever
performers have been hit for sure the
hardest with
everything that's gone on because of not
being able to gather and so
right i i mean i think it's i like
give it to you it's been the hardest um
so
what i mean in typical fashion let's go
back the other direction
like what did you learn in the last year
that you're taking
forward because you had this time that
you'd never had before
because you know you can play the violin
and you can come up with dances and you
can do these things but you're like
you're at home i'm at home i will say
i i did i'm one of the things i'm the
most grateful that i did in this whole
pandemic was i spent a ton of time with
family
something like i went to my sisters for
months stayed at my sister's farm
in missouri with her twins for months of
the pandemic
and it was the best it was the best
decision i ever made and um
you know because at the end of the day
like i i sometimes get so caught up in
what i do and this and being perfect and
task but at the end of the day like my
family is everything and someday i want
to have kids and it was like this really
good reset for me
to like focus on that and just doing a
lot of like self work like
learning about myself and then as far as
the
skills actually this is another reason
i'm grateful for my like
nature as a virgo i guess is that uh i
had this goal i really wanted to do
a virtual show for christmas i wanted to
do something
that would one give my crew work but
also allow us all to be creative
and share something with my fans and so
we made this virtual
christmas show and i wanted to do
something spectacular in it like
that i was like what's something that
would make it special you know because
it's really hard to make a virtual show
special and i decided
i wanted to do a type of aerial art
performing
and i um trained for three months to
hang by my hair
and that's i don't know if you've ever
heard of hair hanging but
i saw it at a cirque du soleil show and
yeah who leaves the cirque show and
thinks to themselves
i want to do that like what yeah my
sister was like you and i are so
different
she's like that looks away from service
so let go i could never do that
that's what you're supposed to do and i
don't know why but i saw one years ago
and there was a hair hanger and i
thought
i'm gonna do that someday and here i was
i had time i was at home and i thought
i can do that and so anyways i spent
like two and a half months training and
it was
the hardest thing i've ever done in my
life and i'm not quite sure why day
after day i went back
and would keep strapping my hair into
this
hook and like being lifted and flying
around i don't know
i don't know why i kept doing it and
even my family was like why are you
doing this
like you're so miserable you know so i
don't know if that's a good thing
or a bad thing because they were all
begging me to stop but
when it came out and it was done
like that was the moment that was the
thing that everybody talked about was
like oh yeah
the hair hanging like what and so you
know i'll never do it again i made that
choice i was like okay
did it done worked so hard to do it but
in a way it was an amazing thing that
helped me remember
that i can do hard things i can push
through
and like we're all so much stronger than
we know we can do these things that like
defy
our understanding um and it was a good
healthy reminder for me to it's been a
while since i did something that felt
impossible
and i think i needed to be reminded of
that
wow you did a lot more with quarantine
than most
[Laughter]
some weird things you know but that's
um that's so true and i believe why do
you think like
somebody like a mom can flip a car over
if their kid's in danger because like
where does this come from does i mean it
fascinates me things like that to
entertain the idea of what is humanly
possible
and i guess what's humanly possible and
what's spiritually possible are probably
um quite different um
[Music]
the spirit comes through the human
that's why there's extraordinary things
that get done
you said that you would go hang out with
your sister and spend time in missouri
and you would
um you you did a lot of work on yourself
and learned about yourself
i've done this throughout time too um
one point in time the most but
i i can resonates with me those words of
like
learning about myself so uh what did you
learn about yourself
oh i just feel like i took a deep dive
back into
kind of like i said i feel like i've
just had to learn the same things over
and over again
and having everything halt made me just
be like a really strong re-evaluation of
like
i've been in this hamster wheel for a
while hamster wheel that i
i think i really like you know but it's
just been turning it's like
album tour music videos to album to you
know just go through the same cycle over
and over again because that's what you
do
and when it stopped just realizing i've
been on it so long that that's the only
value i have
you know and then being on a farm in
missouri where
none of that was possible and
being like what is my actual value come
from
it's like oh it comes through the eyes
of my nieces when they're giggling
because i made them laugh
it comes through the eyes of my sister
as we stayed up late and talked like
that's all that actually matters like it
actually makes me emotional thinking
about it because we all like
do these things to just prove that we're
lovable like
through our entire lives like everybody
just wants to feel like they're lovable
they want to feel like they're enough
and we do crazy things like hanging from
our hair
or like working our tails off
you know or like just groveling for
everyone else to you know on social
media to say that we're enough
but yet it's literally like just in the
eyes of the people that
you actually know it's just in those
moments
like that's all that actually matters
that's where your worth lies and how
often i forget it
every day you know every single day but
when i have those moments and i had so
many of them during covent that just
grilled it back into my head that like
that's what matters
[Music]
it's the danger of being in a routine
um you become forgotten it's like
goes on to that auto program and there's
like
it becomes more of a separation from
that inner child right that's like
wait we were supposed to play we were
supposed to build
a fort in the house with all the
cushions and the pillows
and like watch a movie in there and
it's uh you know that's like where i
think
children are so magic because you know
they remind us
it's like it's like they remind us of
the inner child you know
they bring it back to life again and
um it's very healthy it's very healthy
i'm sure kids can be a real pain in the
ass sometimes but
it's also so cool to watch
it's like you get to relive being a kid
again and
i don't know about you how old you say
you were six when you started playing
the violin
and was it pretty intense like meaning
um
a lot of was it taken very seriously
like i said i had to practice to get my
less
you know or i knew the lessons would
stop but my parents were never like
super grilling about it it was like if i
did my you know
my half hour i was good you know when i
was a little kid but
i mean it's still at the grilling
instrument in general it was every day
but every day yeah it just reminds me
like for me there's so much in my
childhood i don't remember
like i actually don't really remember
much before 10. um
and that i started racing when i was 10
and so
i feel like you know from but from a
very young age i was like
pushed and pushed and like doing
something and so
uh it's almost like i feel like there
was probably some childhood i missed and
so being able to see that through a
child's eyes even something simple like
climbing a tree
it's like it's like you're filling in
the gaps
and like the inner child is like so
happy yes i
love that you know i was on a it's so
funny i went hiking with a friend this
was like
probably two years ago and there was
this random tree
and he goes when was the last time you
climbed a tree
it's like i don't know i don't remember
and he's like
we should climb that tree before i could
even respond to be like i don't think
that's a good idea
because like i'm just like always afraid
i'm gonna hurt my arm or break a
leg and then i'm like well there goes my
tour but he was like halfway up the tree
and so i'm like
okay and i just thought to myself with
like i got up the tree
and was just sitting there as people are
like hiking by you know wondering what
the heck we're doing in the tree but it
was like
yeah i don't climb trees enough i don't
play enough
i don't think anybody does but when you
do it's amazing how like
yeah i never would have climbed that
tree if he hadn't already gone up it you
know and then i was like well that's
lame you know i think hanging from your
hair is an extension play
i mean to do something so crazy and out
there and cool and playful
like what is the next thing that your
sweet little inner child
or even your extremely uh
driven uh high accomplishing
virgo nature is calling in right now
you know i really like that you said
that because i think that
kind of boils it down to something i
hadn't thought of before like i really
think a big reason i wanted to hang by
my hair was like i want to do something
spectacular
like that's the lindsay that was a child
like i want to put on a show for the
neighborhood like
that that's me at my core is there
something else that's come up in you
where you're feeling called
to it um or are you in and
are you okay are you in an allowing flow
of whatever to come
next um or do you feel like i want to do
something
you know i i think right now i'm in a
state of like
re-manifesting things um you know and
i've even just come up with a new way
that i'm like oh i like this it's a new
nightly ritual that
like i feel like it's important to
switch it up every now and then for your
your style of like inner work or like
whatever
your meditation whatever it is and i've
just kind of made a new
form of it for myself where um i think
writing is a really great way for me to
like
um you know it's like i can
aesthetically feel what i'm saying
and so i used to like kind of write
goals every now and then at night and
now i've started this thing where i
i don't actually write i just take my
pen my pen with the lid on
and i close my eyes and i write the
sentences of like
what i've already accomplished you know
like the goals that i have
but i write them as if they're happening
right now or if i'm like excited about
the stage i'm at
in them as if they've already they're
here they came to me um
but as i'm fake writing it or really
writing it but not really um
i visualize it so that i get like
multiple sides of it and then i try to
feel it as i'm writing it about how
excited i am that
this just happened and that like people
loved it and
i had so much fun doing it you know but
i
see it i try to feel it as i'm writing
it and
it's been a kind of a fun way to
manifest and already
one of the things that i've been
manifesting i got a call two days ago
and they're like hey
this uh this writer is excited to like
to write with you and
i i just think there's so much power in
the belief we have and did anyone don't
do that
did anyone teach you that process
because that's totally like
joe dispenza stuff like i mean like like
connecting with the hot
like elevated emotion um and embodying
it
feeling it like getting into it and so
there's a lot of times we'll have a
visceral reaction
there will be like sometimes tears or
sometimes like
joy or like like a smile like there'll
be some genuine
actual manifestation of emotion through
the visualization and
and imagination of it um but no one
taught you that
well i feel like i've i've learned i've
heard people talk about all these
different things
and then this was my best way of because
i actually just listened recently to
like a few of joe dispenza's podcast i
love him
and then um a few lewis house podcasts
that were super inspirational i just
love
kind of like surrounding my life with
bits and pieces of all these things and
then i just took a couple of them and i
was like
well i could write it if i had my eyes
closed i could see it
and so i just made it up based on like
the different things i've heard
wow okay well what else what else is it
what
what what else is on the list then
what's coming because literally
it's coming it's honestly it is it's
been marked in the quantum
and now it's just a matter of time to
line up
with this human experience in the third
dimension but you've literally created
it in the quantum
it's happened it's happened so it's and
i write about
like there's prob there's a list and
some of the things are like work goals
some of them are very like personal like
personality traits that i want to be
better at
you know and it's like the way i want to
show up for other people
and so anyways one of the things is i
just um
gosh we focus so much on ourselves
wherever we go whatever room we walk
into like a lot of times we're worried
about ourselves
i know i am and so i was like i don't
want to do that i like want to walk into
a room
and i want to think about the other
people like i want to put my focus on
them
and energy into them and so i imagine
myself doing that and i write
about that in my little book like that's
one of the things
um and then other goals like i i'm
almost finished with a comic book that
i've been working on for like
two years it's almost done and i'm like
i really want to get that made into a
series like
an animated series or a live action
series so that's
that's one of them wow what is the mo
what it
what is the one that you're almost
embarrassed to say
that seems so ridiculous on the personal
and on the professional side
okay the professional side um oh i
always talk
i always write that i have like the best
show on the vegas strip
that's not laughable that's real but
like
the best one like mine's the most
acclaimed
like oh there's celine dion but then
there's the lindsey sterling show
celine couldn't hang by her hair and
play the violin once
while she danced oh but i can't see but
she did this
she did this then she like sing and like
hit her chest
yeah arm up yes um
and then let's see on the personal side
um
what's the most ridiculous one uh
i don't know if i have any i probably
should have some more like just funny
ones
you know like just awesome random things
but um
i know i like i guess this isn't
ridiculous at all but i like envision my
future family like i really want twins
so i envision my family
with my twins wow that's great
to get two and done one and done for two
exactly i'm like i i'm running out of
time so by the time
that the time is finally right if it
ever comes for me i'm like
let's do two i agree i'm 39 i'm like if
it's ever gonna happen
let's hope it's twins exactly no i'm in
the same boat so
oh my god well i have no doubt that
there's like your list will start to get
checked off
and it's just like that like what's your
favorite way to manifest
yeah i i mean uh start talking about it
writing about it um visualizing it it's
all the same stuff
um just i'd literally take interest that
i want
and i turn them into businesses or if
there's something i'm calling in like
i mean even like designing my perfect
person like i literally
got that it's funny like of all the
things i wrote down about this person
um one of them that i wrote down was
cooks
but so i manifested this person and
so he can't cook at all but he um was a
co-founder of a huge meal delivery
service that
cooked for you know no way
i'm like well i didn't clarify can cook
i just said cook so
that's cool but it was like so crazy how
much of
everything that i wrote down came true
and so writing things down that you want
is i think probably the simplest most
effective way to get
but i do that stuff um i do that stuff
all the time or i went to a week-long
joe dispenza event
um uh not long ago a few months ago
and um he told us to make a mind movie
so since you're so sort of creative so
you just take
it's pictures like you can go on your
phone and use the imovie
and you just take these pictures that
you want to manifest like they're
inspirational photos and then you put a
song to it some song that's really
important
something that will be triggering
something that's meaningful and you put
this song to those photos and then every
time you hear the song
you end up being visualizing the things
in the in the movie in the mind
oh that's very cool oh yeah i've got a
yacht on there a
jet i've got you know all kinds of stuff
in there i've got you know runners for a
marathon when i finally do the boston
you know i've got you know i've got oh
my gosh i needed
yeah i need to up my my list put some
like fun things on there
yeah oh yeah i've got mountains with
skiing mountains for hiking i've got
all kinds of cool stuff so um yeah it's
there's so many ways but you're you're
already doing it and
that is why uh you've already done what
you you
it's in you it's natural it's in you and
so all you're doing is honing those
abilities
and i can't wait to see you uh with
twins and um you know bringing them on
stage at the end of your performance in
vegas
and and being like it happened here i am
here we go
i'll invite you i'll invite you to the
show for sure on opening night
thank you i'll bring my twins too
awesome
amazing congrats on so much you're just
a really really cool person i'm really
um inspired by you and you get it like
there's
there's there's clearly so much um about
this uh you know the the quantum
field of energy that creates things
whether it be
your mind and disassociating with things
or manifesting through writing and
visualizing
you get it you get it there's no mystery
there's no question
that you were meant to be doing what
you're doing well thank you so much
you are such a good interviewer i love
this conversation
you're just so inspired and like yeah i
am really excited so thank you for
having me
you're welcome thank you thanks
everybody for listening to the pretty
intense podcast today i hope you enjoyed
it
if you like what you heard today and you
want to hear more please click
on the subscribe button